justice et vérité une marche silencieuse
et digne la famille et les amis sont en
tête du cortège derrière eux
plus de 200 personnes marchent ainsi du
centre du village de très vite jusqu'à
la ferme de jérôme la rose sur place
marie-pierre une de ses soeurs prend la
parole c'est une journée difficile pour
la famille mais votre présence ici je
pense qu'elle est importante d'abord
parce que si jérôme moi ça quelque part
je pense qu'il en est très très
satisfait très heureux parce qu'il
aimait avoir du monde autour de lui au
centre des prises de parole il y a bien
su rle enquêtes criminelles actuellement
en cours mais aussi le combat de jérôme
pour son métier de paysan pour la
confédération paysanne
l'éleveur est devenu un véritable
symbole jérôme aimant son raison sans
justification sans justice mais elle
restera bien vivant pour les deux
symboles enthousiaste agriculteurs aux
simples consommateurs pour les personnes
présentes
jérôme est bien le symbole d'un monde
paysan écrasés par les contraintes
administratives et économiques graves
qui se passe passe et
des gens qui bossent qui font du très
bon travail
là point de vue agronomique de point de
vue qualitatif d'un produit alimentaire
et qu'on puisse avoir un tel mépris pour
ces gens là c'est ma principale
préoccupation sur ce monde paysan en
tant que consommatrice et d'être nourri
correctement et d'être nourris avec du
local du circuit court et je pense que
jérôme était dans
son circuit là après un pique nique
collectif et la lecture des textes de
jérôme cette journée d'hommage s'est
achevée sur la commune de sailly sur les
lieux mêmes où le jeune paysan a été
abattu